vi sentite tutti prima di cominciare
volevo dirvi che zelda breath of wild è
un gioco open world sconfinato con
paesaggi magnifici e infinite
possibilità di esplorazione
inoltre possiede un sistema di
combattimento avvincenti senza parlare
della possibilità di personalizzare armi
armature cacciare le povere prede che
troveremo lungo il nostro cammino
cucinare le prede che troveremo lungo il
nostro cammino cavalcare al cielo aperto
arrampicarsi sulle torri godersi il
paesaggio e intrattenersi con una
vagonata di sfide secondarie ma prima di
cominciare con il video di oggi la
parola alla principessa zelda
fa vj fa vj mi senti sono la principessa
z
errore controllata dal perfido gun tu
sei la nostra unica speranza vestiti da
eroe e vieni a salvarmi ti prego fate
va bene faccio io faccio salvo io le
principesse qua e là tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a che sono video sono pari j
ed oggi siamo su zelda brief di wired io
negli ultimi due settimane non ho fatto
altro che andare a mangiare andare
accesso e giocare a zelda base un fatto
nient'altro a parte qualche video quando
capita quando abitava allora ragazzi
queste sono tutte le cose che ho già
fatto perché io sto gioco come vi ho
appena detto ci ho giocato da tanto
veramente campo allora questo il mio
personaggio
se sei veramente bravissimo 4 brutto su
disegno lo facevo meglio io allora
questo il mio personaggio ci sono le
questo le mie armi questa è la squadra
suprema che ho già preso un casino
prendere sto spada ma io l'ho già presa
noemi armi questi sono i miei archi
questo il newton e scudi e poi un sacco
di cose cucinate perché in questo gioco
puoi cucinare io non so cucinare una
mazza dal vivo però in zelda so fare le
cose cioè le ricette ecco questo sono
per cucinare gli faccio vedere
brevemente come si cucina perché fa
troppo rigido e prendi due ingredienti
adesso vi piglio completamente a caso
prendiamo il pollame e lo puoi unire ad
altri ingredienti ad esempio metti il
salgemma che sarebbe il sale e quindi
facciamo il pollo sale vabbè funghi dai
funghi carne al sale coi funghi e
cannavacciuolo può accompagnare solo si
cucina così zelda prendi una cosa del
boot in pentola e poi finisce che c'è il
piatto tutto sul vassoio che ci sono
delle mele me le prendo perché le mail e
servono a farti ringraziare i cavalli
che fischi
io nella vita reale se fischio mi arriva
pietro purtroppo fresco si chiama il mio
cavallo non chiedetemi perché comunque
ragazzi questo video vedevo concentrarlo
più sul dlc che aggiunge un sacco di
cose tra le quali la spada che avete
appena visto quella che ciò la spada
suprema con il dlc c'e una quest che
vuoi fare che te la potenza e volevo
farla da giorni
non vedevo l'ora di registra sto video
per fargli capire quella lara l'armatura
che sto usando ti dà possibilità di
arrampicarti meglio infatti ci ho messo
una vita a prenderla perché in sella ti
puoi arrampicare puoi usare anche la
parola para vela che gli fa planare da
un punto all'altro è fighissimo l'unica
roba che devo ancora fare e potenziale
che è successo ciao albero come una voce
ti ha detto di venire qui non è stato
gli lcd ho comprato e c'era scritto che
dovevamo ogni anno protezione in tuo
possesso ti verrà tolta avrai affrontare
i nemici di sarre marche sono nudo oddio
di successo come sa non la uso la spada
combatte coi pugni come combatto
spiegano ma sono nudo prescelto dalla
spada suprema supera la prova della
spada e poi splendere la sua vera luce
da nudo nudi mi fate capire un attimo
come aiuto a c'è un ramo per te devo
combattere come un ramo alle bombe cielo
a mignano almeno le bombe questi sono i
gruppi lin che sono i nemici più scarsi
di tutti ovvero lei si è uno è andato
due sono andati di terremoto perfetto
grazie grazie a tutti grazie a tutti a
posto
chi rullino vabbè almeno trovato
qualcosa per recuperar vita anche se fa
un po schifo e lo andrei qua per andrea
ok credo che la situazione si faccia di
volta in volta sempre più difficile o mi
sbaglio
no perché so già che se muoio alla fine
devo ripartire da zero lo so già io
è schiatta ok ciao zio frate stai calmo
perché io io con il combattimento non
sono come un fenomeno nave lo dico io lo
faccio abbastanza schifo però vado a che
botta ragazzi questo è per voi buon
natale ma per adesso è andata abbastanza
bene era che però credetemi intanto non
finirà bene questo volendo lo assicuro
proprio quello sotterraneo 4 e vabbè
quanto casi nato sta diventando vecchia
testa bomba c'era che per adesso sta
andando abbastanza bene ma non credo
durerà tanto che c'è un tizio non l'ho
visto ai e papere quanto male
[Musica]
poi ma che fece a sto tizio maschiata
vado a wall street ha fatto un volo
incredibile per adesso non fatti 5 non è
niente male
già questo non riuscirò a farlo perché
vedo già un tizio che gigante poi non lo
batto neanche morto
buon compleanno questi qua non volevo
neanche con l'economist i quali sono
imbattibili ragazzi
madonna che posta ce l'ho fatta ok sono
veramente resistenti stitici sono
ribatto così non li non mi avvicino
neanche perché mi sciocca ma stai calma
e stanga
e basta
ciao vuoto madonna quanto male io ho
fatto ho vinto ne ho fatte 6
spero sia finito perché non so quanto
questa sfida e un'ora che combatto
contro nemici la cosa che mi spaventa è
che se muoio ricomincio da capo tutto ci
fosse gesù bosasso rock no non lo
battero mai sasso rock nora cavolo giuro
non è vero mai gli spoiler o che perdono
[Musica]
è caduto saluto veloce ai vai vai light
non è vero non sai neanche arrampicata
bravissimo dai frate mamma mia quanto
lento a dare un attacco
preso ma giu vai giù giù giù giù bravo
ok e schiatta di quanto duri non è vero
non è vero non è vero non è vero non può
essere rimasta così poca vita
maledizione colpito a
attento che ti schiaccia dentro dispiace
yes contro un sasso gigante ce l'ho
fatta non credevo di farcela ve lo giuro
per questo se mi toccava ero morto in un
colpo immagino ce ne siano 10 siamo al
sesto che ho fatto con di settimo credo
siano 10 perché più di dieci impossibile
però se questo era già difficile quelli
dopo cosa sono
questo finito raga forza ho finito non
ci credo non lo so di quello salteranno
7 poi un punto in cui prendo armature
cose ho vinto però non penso di aver
vinto sincero lancia ma perché imitate
armi
datemi armature maledizione che sbottano
a capo su cucinare vero
meno male almeno la cucina facciamo un
frutto e funghi faccio io che sono chef
conosco le cose vai frutta cotta va bene
abbiamo fatto la pausa merenda fatemi
salvare la partita non si sa mai
adesso non puoi salvare gli es
perché se mi ha riempito di cose così è
perché questo era solo l'inizio
ecco giacché più buio mi mette mi mette
caga prove no no quelle sono elettriche
maledizione no quelle elettriche le odio
non muoio muoio muoio mangia porca vacca
che botta
niente non posso farci nulla ragazzo ai
difficili non c'è veramente sta
particolarmente un cadetto
se magari non vado a nuotare nel lago
maledizione mentre combatto anch'io sono
stupido puoi morire per favore ok ok
perfetto no perché quanto levante ok
quello già mi ha visto non sembra anche
partiti già mi ha visto e ha già
richiamato gli altri pure no alla gaf
armi e vabbè è quel si no puoi togliermi
un po di più per cortesia perché miccoli
poco malus che ci va bene software non
so no no ma no non è possibile non si
può c'è una porca vacca cioè se non ho
finito adesso non vinco mai basta quanto
quante sfide ci sono con te siamo undici
non è possibile ci ve lo giuro
no aragami è uno scherzo non si può non
si può fare
una donna che male no no non ci va
mandava massima da una guerra nucleare
già già che ci siamo tanto è un bene
perché sarei dovuto morire molto prima
cioè io in realtà sono molto sulla
destra
non mi do neanche una speranza guarda
c'è riuscito a farli fuori
ciao le lei lei e di qua allora tutto
l'ho preso a frecciate da un chilometro
e mezzo sprecato qualcosa come 20
freccero un arco però adesso con quale
faccia vado allo scontro successivo me
lo dite voi con tre cuori e mezzo e le
armi che fanno schifo moriamo con onore
al 12 questo potrebbe essere il boss
finale la cosa mi fa adirare alquanto
ragazzi non ho mai affrontato una roba
del genere non so come batterlo non ne
ho idea
quando gli ho tolto o non mi sa dire
quanto gli 88 niente un quarto di vita
lui e fa bene praga sono morto però con
onore perché ho combattuto fino alla
fine l'importante ragazzi e crederci poi
magari fai schifo come me però ci credi
questo ha preso un albero come arma ma
siamo scemi
[Musica]
andiamo sul sacrario della rinascita
perché perché tra il dlc della ballata
dei campioni e tra di lc delle prove
leggendarie hanno aggiunto un sacco di
roba se tu vai nel punto dove partì
proprio in gel da questo il punto
iniziale del gioco teoria dovrebbe
succedere qualcosa al sacrario della
nascita cms qua c'è un coro che avevo
trovato io c'è niente a questo io della
prova per domare un colosso sacco si sta
roba
una forchetta per avviare la prova
impugnare la spada a questa è una spa è
una spada questa vai col piatto di
spaghetti gigante con i miei ecco con il
piatto di spaghetti di mia nonna lo
mangiava con questa non poté mangiarlo
se non era un casino cos'è
si si lascia davvero no perché voi non
lo sapete ma ci sono certe armi che per
averle devi ttt esce tutta la barra
della vita
solo sei abbastanza fuori poi averle io
ne ho 15 quindi ce l'ho fatta a superare
questa prova necessaria e grande
perseveranza
ok codesta spada sconfigge nemici non
solo il colpo ma anche chi l'ha
brandisce sarà sconfitto al primo colpo
recate 4 punti segnati subito sì
l'abbiamo fammi recuperare la vita mia
mi è rimasta un quot ma ben mangiante
mangiato
[Musica]
fatemi capire che chi è il mio nemico
mostrati a questi gruppi no vabbè novità
ok c'è presidente semi semi semi
sfruttano sono morto e questo no vabbè
ma anche la lanciano è fattibile
ok sono vivo per miracolo perché io non
sto zitto modelli ei ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto io concludo qua il video
di zen da spero che siate più bravi di
me nel combattimento comunque al di là
del fatto che perdo il gioco in sé è
veramente una bomba incredibile cioè io
normalmente ve lo giuro non faccio così
schifo cosa precisamente mi piace anche
questo comitato tedeschi sia l'azione
aver fischiato e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video è successo lynn succede
bill è presente stavo giocando prima di
dormire noi sono tornato muto alla fine
mezzanotte passata tra poco dovrei
andare a dormire ma mi metto a
riprendere questa cosa perché voglio
farvi vedere quanto sono disagiato devo
battere il gigante se batto il gigante
internet si dovrebbe come si vede anche
nel riflesso ciao
no non gli devo niente non è vero ma
quanto mi ha tolto nell'universo
no no no no non posso più correre mi è
mancato dai dai
lo faccio fuori con le frecce con le
frecce se è gay ma mia raga non potevo
non farcela ragazzi era impossibile o
fatta fatemi uscire per l'amor di dio
basta ci vuole una vetilia sono
contentissimo ciao mamma sono famoso
oh mio dio locato cadeau muoio e perdo
tutto perché questa è la spada la
splendida per l'amor di dio prendi ha
perso la vita per cercare di fare questo
livello
mi ha potenziato la spada la spada
suprema adesso leva 40 e non più 30
direi che possa andare a dormire
contenuto buonanotte ragazzi
[Musica]